so now comes the difficult part for the
left to admit and quite frankly the sad
part
and i'll get to the conclusion up front
so you know what we're talking about
we are losing the battle of ideas the
left is losing the battle of ideas in
the united states right now and it is
not because our ideas aren't good
many of the ideas are good and other
countries have already figured out
that not only are the right idea are
they the right ideas but they work
it's because the rights ideas only need
to spread a little
for them to be quote effective and have
an impact where the ideas of the left
often require because they are
progressive
egalitarian ideas the ideas of the left
often require institutional support and
legislation
and much more infrastructure and i hate
to admit this
but if we don't accept this and
understand it we will never win
okay so again context just to remind
everybody today we are talking so much
about the shootings that took place and
related
issues we are going to get fully
demonetized for covering these issues
now if we were weaker what we would do
is just pick stories for today that
would be monetized but these issues are
so
important that we are just doing an
entire show that will be demonetized on
youtube
please help us out with that support us
directly ideally with a membership at
joinpacman.com
any discussions of gun safety or
whatever else after an incident
are always demonetized by youtube
so we have these shootings and then
immediately
the pro-gun movement goes into effect
any discussions about gun safety after a
shooting
are called politicized by the pro-gun
right this
isn't the right time to talk about those
things and then if we wait a little
while and they say
and then we say let's talk about them
now let's now do now that we're not
right after a tragedy
let's do some of this gun safety stuff
then they say we don't even have a
problem when was the last mass shooting
that we had and usually it's only like a
couple of weeks but
it doesn't matter that's their argument
and one of the ideas
that we have sort of lost on is the idea
that
guns shouldn't be seen as a way to solve
problems there's the debate which i will
talk about in a second
about specific gun safety regulations
but
the left has lost a bigger culture fight
this country has a sickness which is
that too many people
see guns as a way to solve their
personal problems
they see guns as a way to solve societal
problems they see guns as a way to solve
cultural and economic problems we
will not win until we root out that
malignancy and in the meantime we're not
even going to reduce
the the mass shootings until we make it
more difficult to carry out some of
these ideas by making the guns more
difficult to come by and this is where
we have to understand
that even just within gun safety
there are such simple things that we
just can't get done
because ultimately there isn't enough
overwhelming support for them where it
matters
universal background checks okay we
couldn't pass universal background
checks after the sandy hook shooting
with democrats controlling the white
house the house and the senate
if we can't do it then i don't know that
we can ever do it
without some wholesale realignment of
american culture
period stricter mental health or psyche
vows for all gun sales with restrictions
based on outcomes
depending on the outcome of those psych
evals restrictions on
firearm ownership that are stricter and
apply to all gun sales period
we just can't do it focusing bans on
certain ammunition types and
modifications that make it even harder
for law enforcement to subdue a shooter
before they or really when we talk about
shooters we're talking about
he before he can do more damage our
takeaways have to be
the goal must be the total
destruction of the political movement
known as modern republicanism which now
includes trumpism
because we can talk about bipartisanship
we can listen to some of the democratic
candidates uh
you know talk about how they are going
to get things done with republicans
we will make no progress while these
people controlled the white house or the
senate
or the house of representatives this is
not by the way
a pat on the back to democrats we still
won't get a ton of stuff
if democrats are in power but we might
get
some basic things some gun safety
some more funding and access to mental
health treatment but now
we on the left need to look at ourselves
as well as the platforms that we're on
okay this is a responsibility thing as
well if you look at the manifesto of the
el paso shooter
and you consider that he posted
something to the radical right message
board
8chan before the shooting you come to
realize something those calls i get
from young people who say hey i was
radicalized by the right wing online
echo chamber
but then i found the david pakman show
and then i found kyle kalinski and i
found others
and it's so great you guys
de-radicalized me that is great
but just as it was merely by chance that
some of my audience was de-radicalized
because they stumbled upon my videos
or kyle's or sam cedars or someone
else's those same people
once they were in the rabbit hole could
have just as easily been brought even
further down the other side and been
pushed
from being alt-righters who were not
willing to do actual violence
they could have been pushed into the
people that do actual
violence and ultimately uh end up in the
news
the way that shooters over the weekend
have so what i'm saying is
there are so many people in society
right now whose ideology
is so malleable i mean it's like putty
that
merely by chance by algorithmic
coincidence
it could be they go from ben shapiro to
stefan molyneux
and off to the right and committing
violence in the real world or
they could just by that same possibility
of algorithmic echo chambers
go from ben shapiro to david pakman to
kyle kolinsky
and that could actually be the
difference between someone committing
real world violence or not and
i'm not saying that this is now it's
david pakman and kyle kolinsky
who will be the undoing of violence in
society that's not what i mean what i'm
pointing out is
in the same way that by chance some
people get
de-radicalized by these online echo
chambers and algorithms
totally beyond our control some will
just as easily be radicalized into
violence
i'm always careful not to say any two
extremists are the same
or that anything is like the nazis or
that anyone is
hitler but we also have to look really
specifically at pre-world war ii germany
in the 20s and 30s
and the current circumstances in the
united states there are
too many similarities to ignore that
doesn't mean another holocaust is coming
but what we need to understand
is when we talk about fascism and
authoritarianism there are too many
similarities here that are more
evidence that we are losing in a great
way on the left
the use of the propaganda technique of
repeating lies until people believe them
trump relies on this and it works and we
are losing around it we are merely
playing catch-up around it
hitler like trump was sort of like an
ignorant uneducated showman
who lacked a lot of basic knowledge
about the world but pulled
people in with catch phrases and simple
ideas
because he at least had a sense of what
got people's attention that's very
similar to donald trump
similarly anti-internationalism was a
big thing in post-world war one germany
which mixes with isolationism germany
had this in that period before world war
ii
we're seeing it again in the u.s in
trump with the idea of separating from
europe and our allies
building walls keeping brown people out
protectionism on trade we are seeing
that as well
self-victimization trump is the victim
of everybody right the democratic party
trump's the victim journalist trump's
the victim the fake news media trump's
the victim everyone is victimizing trump
the way german propaganda claimed that
germany
was being victimized in the period
before world war ii
and we can't ignore what we're talking
about here in the context of these mass
shootings
in the same way that we saw it in
pre-world war ii germany donald trump is
using the thinly veiled promotion of
violence
through these coded messages and the
suggestive vocabulary he uses
this is another similarity so we on the
left need a full accounting
and plan here because this needs to stop
but we're only going to start being able
to do that if we first recognize that
yes we're losing the battle of ideas
because they win much more easily than
we do example
we want health care for all we want to
reduce income inequality we want to stop
pointless wars
we want to totally take apart the
military-industrial complex
how do we do that well we've got to be
activists for that
for years working to change public
opinion such that we will
elect people who will ultimately do
those things
but the other side just needs some
radical nuts
to on the same weekend go and open fire
because they hate immigrants and it's a
win for them so when i say we're losing
the battle i don't mean we have the
wrong ideas
i don't mean we aren't communicating
communicating them effectively even
though
we could probably communicate them in a
better way what i mean is that the
threshold for winning
is so much lower for them and i don't
know how we fight that
so that that's where my commentary ends
i would love to at this point say
and then here is what we do
unfortunately i don't know what we do
and i want to hear from you about it we
will have a poll about this
on our instagram page at david pakman
show follow me on instagram while you're
there at david.pakman it will be
um a very long week of trying to sort
out
a lot of this and i'm glad that you'll
be here with me in order to do that